We live in a world of overuse type,
tentatively still,
it's hard to overstate the phenomenon that is youtube and just over a decade,
it has risen from nothing to 70 billion hours of video watched every month.
It is also the third most visited site on the Internet with 80 percent of
viewers coming from outside the United States.
It has more than one point 5 billion monthly users who are entertained by 400
hours worth of video,
uploaded every 60 seconds and on top of all of that,
it's made a lot of people a lot of money,
but have you ever stopped and wondered how Youtube came about?
It's a fascinating story and today you're going to discover it all as we go
behind the scenes to bring you the real youtube story
said with a chance encounter in 1999,
Eric Skaggs,
a local entrepreneur,
was finishing up some work on his website at the College of Business Computer
Lab at Indiana University in Pennsylvania.
His website was called,
go get it now.
Josh carbon was an amalgamation of email search engine and web hosting combined
into a single interface as he was about to leave the building.
Scag saw a tall guy and a baseball cap coming in.
They struck up a conversation and skaggs learned that this guy was Chad Hurley.
He was a graphics arts may job who was looking for an idea for a website.
The idea that skaggs gave to honey wants to provide to the inspiration for the
youtube revolution.
He told him that in the future,
television and computers would become fully integrated.
Furthermore,
people would be able to use their cell phones to create home videos and they
would want a platform to share them with friends and family.
Remember,
this was all at a time when there were no cameras in phones and TV and the
Internet were very different animals.
The idea of,
well,
it was a little overwhelming for her,
the and distorted away for future reference.
After graduating from Indiana University with a finance degree,
these started looking for employment in the exciting new internet industry.
He picked up a wired magazine from his local grocery store,
which featured the top 10 internet companies.
Holly sat down and redesigns those companies' logos,
sending them to the marketing departments of the respective companies,
the one he did for a company that you might have heard of paper or caught the
eye of co founder Elon Musk,
and before he knew as Hurley was hired as the company's first graphic designer,
it was a paypal that holly was able to pick the brains of the most brilliant
techie neds in the industry.
The two smartest guys in the room where Steve Chen and corrine Shannon was born
in Taiwan in 1978 with this family moving to the United States when he was eight
years old,
he had attended the Illinois Mathematics and science academy where he proved to
be a math prodigy.
His passion was computer engineering and he went on to study computer science at
the University of Illinois.
He began working for paypal in 1999.
A few months before holly had was born in Germany in 1979.
Moving with his family to the US when he was 13,
from the stance,
Joanne was a computer whiz in school.
He wrote computer programs,
posting them on the Internet for free.
It also helps to set up the school's email system,
just like Steve Chen.
Karen went to the University of Illinois where he studied computer science after
a number of internships with a range of technology companies.
He sought employment with paypal in the year 2000 where he was put to work on
designing the company's anti fraud security system early.
The graphic designer Chen,
the engineer and Korean.
The systems go real soon,
found each other and spends more and more time brainstorming ideas for their own
startup.
For five years,
they kicked around ideas while building up that knowledge and experience a
paypal.
Then in January of 2005,
he was hosting a dinner party at his home.
Jen was in attendance and he began using a camcorder to take some video of the
festivities.
The next day they wanted to share the video with those who had been in
attendance.
The problem was that the video files were way too big to send diver email,
and even though there were a few photo sharing websites such as flicker and
shutterfly,
nothing existed for the sharing of video online.
It was at this point that the seed that had been planted years before came to
life teaming up with Korean.
They decided to create a website to share videos.
The idea was to use the video sharing platform to create a dating site.
People would post videos of themselves and they could view these and respond if
they liked what they saw.
They called it tune in hookup.
They launched this site within days and then waited for the users to come are
the world.
Nothing happens in an attempt to get some content up on the site.
They placed ads on craigslist offering to pay people to post videos.
Still no one was interested and tune in hookup became a huge flop.
The trio,
they were disheartened,
but it's not dismayed.
Shortly after the demise of their first joint venture,
Joanne was frustratingly searching online for a video of Janet Jackson's
infamous 2004 superbowl halftime show wardrobe malfunction because there was no
user friendly platform for sharing video content.
He wasn't able to satisfy his breast fetish together with Harley and Chen.
He designed it to do something about it,
stripping away the Lane Dayton concepts if they were left with a video uploading
and sharing platform,
or they needed now was a name for that website
on February the 14th,
2005,
and a humble apartment above a California pizza shop.
The trio began building their new website initially,
the apparently in reference to Janet Jackson's unwitting contribution that they
wanted to call it a boob tube,
realizing that that sounded too much like a porn site that they began playing
around with words that conveyed the idea of personalized television.
Harking back to the days when the TV was called the tube,
thanks to the Catholic rate,
you've that powered is one of the three.
No one knows which one came up with youtube.
It sounded perfect.
They were short,
catchy,
fun,
and it perfectly summed up what they were about.
When early applies to register the domain name,
the idea was to go with youtube with a view instead of y o u,
however that domain was already taken,
which forced him to proceed a tube,
but with the three letter word,
you hurley each and immediately set about writing down the goals for at the top
of that list was ease of user experience loading and to watching videos had to
be super easy so that even the most computer illiterate person could do it.
They've been divided up the workload.
Chad Hailey was in charge of the look and design of the site is well.
There's tagging and labeling uploaded videos to make them easier for viewers to
find.
Steve,
Jen was the engineered.
He made sure that the site was running smoothly and that video's played without
lagging to read.
Korean.
Meanwhile uses programming skills to get the site up and running and looking
great.
Unlike the other two,
Korean chose not to be an employee of the company.
Instead,
his role is that of an informal advisor.
This allowed him to focus on the graduate studies and computer science at
Stanford University.
The first video ever uploaded onto youtube was an 18 seconds long of Korean,
but the San Diego Zoo entitled me at the zoo.
You can still watch this historic clip on the site where it has been seen by
more than 30 million people.
Holly,
he was put in charge of marketing.
He started a competition where different youtube used though was given an Ipod
Nano every day for eight weeks.
People aren't points by referring a friend or posting a video.
The more points you gains,
the greater your chances of winning the ipod.
The promotion works and people began to flooding the site with video concepts.
However,
this it created a problem.
So much content was coming on board that youtube was running out of bandwidth.
This made video playback,
excrutiatingly slaves.
They were desperately in need of more storage capacity which required money,
but as of yet so they weren't making any.
Fortunately on the basis of future ad revenue forecasts,
they were able to secure a three point $5,000,000 venture capital loan in
November of 2005 just a month earlier.
A nice promotional video featuring Brazilian football star Renelle denia became
the first youtube clips or reach 1 million views
by the beginning of 2006 youtube grains and more than 60 employees and the site
had more than 100 million views.
This was an astounding level of growth considering that just 12 months earlier,
they literally couldn't pay people to post videos on their website.
Over the course of its first year.
The nature of the content is being loaded onto youtube.
It evolved for the first few months.
The majority of clips were of the home movie variety,
but then more and more how to videos began appearing with advice being offered
on how to do everything from changing the oil in your car,
do the proper technique for doing a barbell squat.
As a result,
youtube was fast becoming the goatee source for both entertainment and
information.
In June,
2006,
youtube ends to contract with NBC television.
Say you turned by NBC.
He would previously forced you to.
You have to remove the Saturday night live clip after it became viral online.
Now,
NBC agreed to pay you to you,
but to place promotional clips of their shares.
These were things such as behind the scenes,
interviews and other features.
Youtube was by now we're attracting the attention of the biggest players in the
web universe.
The site was wildly popular with viral videos,
regularly appearing on TV,
news broadcasts,
and even entire being devoted to youtube content.
The sort of global reach that Youtube had acquired was extremely inviting to the
biggest player of them all.
In October of 2006,
the Google Corporation purchased you to you for a staggering,
at one point six,
$5 billion dollars.
The three tech notes from paypal now have more money than they could possibly
spend an entire lifetime.
Just like being independently wealthy beyond measure early,
and Jen stayed with Youtube.
In fact,
they were thrilled to be working with central web giants as Google.
They now had the freedom to focus on adding new technology to the website in an
effort to encourage people to stay on the site for longer.
They added extra features including suggestions of follow up videos that the
viewer might be interested in watching.
They also set to work on making the youtube experience available through a
greater range of devices.
Youtube is mobile.
App lets people watch videos on their cell phones and people could now add a
youtube clips,
do that websites and their blogs.
It'll move.
It emphasized just how dominant youtube was in people's lives.
Time magazine featured a youtube screen on the cover of it's 2006 person of the
year,
issue
in May,
2007,
but partner program that was launched.
This allowed people who uploaded videos to have a share in the ad revenue
generated by the advertising that was played during their video.
Now for the first time,
everyday people were able to tend their hobbies into successful online
businesses.
The program which is still in operation today,
pays uploaders around 55 percent of the ad revenue over the last decades.
This revenue source has paid off big time for a relatively small number of
creators who are known as Youtube,
as people have created massive followings and huge annual earnings.
They've also been able to leverage their popularity to obtain sponsorship deals
with merchandisers who are keen to get their products in the videos.
Some of these youtubers have even landed movie and TV roles.
As a result of that online fame,
2007 was also the year that youtube began impacting politics.
Seven of the 13 candidates for the presidency of the United States announced
their campaigns through youtube.
This was followed by the first youtube presidential debates which featured
questions submitted by viewers.
Then in 2009,
the capability was introduced to to upload and watch three d videos on youtube.
Well,
that same year,
these staggering milestone of 1 billion views per day was reached.
Less than three years later,
that number had mushroomed to 4 billion.
The first video to reach 1 billion views once the unforgettable gangnam style by
psy,
which reached the milestone on December the 21st 2012 in 2011.
The new feature of live streaming was added.
Now,
major world events can be watched in real time making youtube a viable
alternative to the television Sas because youtube was soon to prove that it was
more than just a recorder of historical events.
January the 25th,
2011 was a day of protest against the government of President Mubarak in Cairo,
Egypt.
Throughout that day,
video of the proclaimed a day of rage began appearing on this inspired and
emboldened thousands of Egyptian citizens who came pouring out into the streets.
The protests went on for 18 days and the protesters were able to use youtube
along with facebook and twitter to galvanize the support that would eventually
lead to change.
Uber x regime reacted to the skillful use of the Internet on the positive it's
detractors by imposing a sweeping crackdown of the Internet.
This only further enraged the protesters eventually forcing move or act to step
down and democratic elections to be held for the first time in decades in 2011,
there was also a major overhaul of the websites.
Look,
the video channels were displayed in a central column and the Youtube logo was
updated.
The Google chrome browser was also integrated so that viewers could watch
youtube at directly through Google.
Plus two years after that,
youtube began offering paid subscriptions for a monthly feed.
This service allowed subscribers do you watch longer ad free videos as well as
movies,
so one of the founders of youtube up to now,
well in October of 2010,
Chad Hurley steps down the CEO of youtube handing over the reigns to Salonica
Monga he committed to staying on as an advisor to the company.
Steve Chen left the company.
It's about the same time and the teeth again,
working together on a new venture,
a systems.
Their headline product was an iphone app called a mixed base,
which allows users to shoot,
edit,
and share video clips.
Avl Systems has acquired a number of other companies,
including delicious and tap 11 chantelle.
It was also a major sponsor of the USF one formula one racing team.
He is also a part owner of the NBA team,
the Golden State Warriors,
and the mls,
Los Angeles football club.
In 2014,
after 15 years of collaboration,
Chen and Harley parted company jobs took over full control of mixed base while
Chen went over to Google ventures as an entrepreneur in residence,
making it clear that there was no animosity in the passing.
Chen explains actually it was a very personal and difficult decision to make,
but with the decisions as an Avon to mix this,
it became pretty clear mixed.
It was chance idea before we started Davis and even at Youtube and if I feel
driven to work on other projects,
then I'm just getting in the way of mixed bit and the team and corrine completed
his graduate studies at the University of Illinois in emerging with a master's
degree in computer science.
Of the three founders.
He received the lowest portion of stock.
However,
this was still enough for him to around $64,000,000 from the sale to Google in
2018 launch to university ventures,
which provides mentorship,
expertise and contacts for college students who wants to take innovative
projects to the next level.
Grimm was also one of the first investors in Airbnb in 2009 towards the end of
2013 crim hit the headlines when he objected along with many other youtube users
to Google's requirements that commenting on youtube videos only be done through
a google plus account.
He showed his displeasure by changing the description on his iconic near the zoo
video to read.
I cannot comment here anymore since I don't want a google plus account.
As a result of Karen stance backs up by a 240,000 signature petition,
Google dropped its requirements that commenters must use their google plus
products.
It is truly mind blowing to contemplate just how big youtube will become the
next few years.
New Features are constantly being rolled out to enhance the viewer experience
has already replaced tv as the main source of entertainment information from any
people.
According to Google executive chairman,
Eric Schmidt,
the exponential growth of youtube will bring it six or 7 billion unique visitors
per month.
With that growth largely being driven from the developing world,
Youtube has become a launching pad for a growing number of breakout stars
including Justin Bieber and Grayson chance.
There have even been a number of TV shows that began life as youtube skits,
including broad city and workaholics.
Youtube is the most public place in the world,
accessible from the privacy of our own bedrooms.
It has created unprecedented opportunities for learning,
entertaining,
and earning a living,
but just like anything,
youtube,
it can be abused.
For one thing,
it can be mind numbingly addictive.
You might sit down to watch a three minute clip him three hours later.
You're still slouched in front of the computer watching cats playing piano or
hopefully you know,
watching one of our videos as well.
Speaking of biographics videos,
please do not forget to subscribe.
We put out brand new videos every Monday and Thursday.
Now,
obviously this video was a bit different.
It's all first biography of a company.
Please let us know what you think of it in the comments below.
Also give it a like if you did like it,
suggestions for companies that you might be interested in us doing.
Again,
leave those in the comments and as always,
thank you for watching.